and now to present our first two awards
of the 2011 Spirit Awards our Josh
Radnor and two times Spirit Award
nominee Anna Kendrick
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Josh Radnor
and I'm Anna Kendrick we're so happy to
present this first Spirit Award to
appropriately the best first screenplay
the awards for new talents are very
close to the heart and soul of film
independent the nominees are Best first
screenplay
Diane Belle absolute Ian so you're
writing an encyclopedia I can't help but
think why you came out here to talk to
me I wanted to see if you were a
reliable source lena dunham tiny
furniture
poor things I'm really tired
I took three klonopin and woke up next
to a spoonful of peanut butter you like
toys yeah
Nik Fackler lovely still justice woman
she wants to go on a date there is a lot
of planning that goes into these things
a lot of strategies it's like you're a
soldier
solid she's a soldier he has a soldier
of love oh well Bob bloody knee jack
goes boating I told him I loved him he
was a great dad and he was free to go to
heaven yeah
two days later he woke up out of the
coma fuck God and then he fell down and
hit his head in the hallway and then he
died disappearo and Evan and wieners
monogamy Sunday television and laptops
and beds I like sound I don't like
shopping for sale Lena Dunham for tiny
furniture
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much thank you
I didn't this is not presumptuousness I
promised my dad I would write something
down cuz he saw me be very unprepared
when I gave a high school graduation
speech so I swore thank you so much so I
first want to thank the people who made
tiny furniture with me Kyle Martin and
Alicia Vancouver Aang the producers your
effectiveness and creativity astounds me
every day Thank You Lance Edmonds my
brilliant editor I know these aren't
people who contributed to the screenplay
but I just need to shout them out Jody
Lee likes the DP who's mine blows my
mind and who I didn't understand the
term filmmaker till I worked with you
the cast David call Alex Karpov ski whoo
I just hit in the balls on the red
carpet I'm so sorry
Merritt Wever Jemima Kirke who's my muse
Peter Benedict and Jenny Mary ocess your
support means everything to me
Josh bran who sold with the IFC which is
such a unique and brave company and has
a truly independent spirit and I feel so
lucky Ryan Cheney film independent this
is incredible all the voters this is as
always for my family I feel so lucky to
have born been born to my two best
friends and then my other best friend
was born and she was a little younger
than me and I just I thank you this is
surreal thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is anything gonna happen it's alright
should I improvise something this next
award oh okay this is exciting
oh we're back alright the next award for
Best Cinematography honors the artists
who create the slightly alien worlds
where independent films take place the
nominees are Best Cinematography Adam
Kimmel never let me go
Matthew Lee batik Black Swan
[Applause]
[Music]
Jody Lee likes tiny furniture
[Applause]
Michael McDonough Winter's Bone
[Music]
[Applause]
Paris adidas greenberg
[Music]
[Music]
and the Spirit Award goes to
Matthew Liberty
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
so amazing me back here it took me in a
11 years to be back here since the last
time I was able to visit it's uh it's
humbling to be around so much creativity
in one room so Thank You IFC I want to
shout out to my wife the muse to my
craft my life mahalik Larsen Yanni I
want to say hello to my kids you're
gonna watch this later
Ezekiel inaud you I love you I miss you
every day I'm not with you thank you
thank you thank you what a year for
independent cinema 127 hours a truly
amazing film for me 127 hours is more
than just a tale of survival it's a
gut-wrenching real-life story of a brave
young man who tried desperately to
masturbate with his non-dominant hands
and Danny Boyle you you've gone from
directing the most disturbing Indian
tourism commercial ever to the most
harrowing Mountain Dew commercial ever
kudos incredible Winter's Bone Winter's
Bone what a movie holy crap
if you if you can can only see one movie
this year that features heavy meth use
abusive parents and squirrel skinning
make it Gnomeo and Juliet but we're just
going pretty good - yeah make time for
that you can keep scrolling there go up
there's a joke
the kids are all right is a great
example of how our definition of family
is changing to include everything from
same-sex parents to sperm donor fathers
to even someone who would be willing to
marry a ginger so I didn't get it either
my albino a bundle right I wrote that
one so uh alright moving up Black Swan
Black Swan Wow
blew me away amazing filmmaking flawless
performances they believe a lasting
impact on the history of cinema as a
searing portrait of artistic commitment
or at the very least as that movie where
the girl from that 70s show eats out
Luke Skywalker's mom
so sorry
sorry I didn't want sorry so black swuan
the kids are alright
Greenberg Blue Valentine what do these
movies all have in common that's right
cunnilingus yes 2010 will go down as the
year of cinematic cunnilingus blowjobs
no those are the domain of big studio
movies for the indie darlings of 2010 it
was all about eatin lunch down at the Y
between these films and the King's
Speech the lesson was clear if you want
to make it an independent cinema work on
your tongue exercises this is a good
time to point out my mom and dad are
here tonight and they really are the
better table in Warren so here we go
with the show and now two people who
have to bravely walk onstage after my
extended run of cunnilingus jokes please
welcome Mark Ruffalo and Vera Farmiga
[Music]
they're new they're new boots did you
get the cunnilingus jokes Thank You Joel
it's great to be back here where we all
belong having a picnic lunch and a tent
on the beach and freezing I'm always
glad to be back at the Independent
Spirit Awards because it means that I'm
still significant and cool although we
are going to be announcing winners here
today the independent film community
doesn't speak with one voice that's
where the independent part comes in no
vote is unanimous and no choice we make
here today will be any more than the
first among equals in other words we all
kick ass
in addition to finding out who won and
who lost we hope that you'll all get the
big picture about our community who we
are and where we're headed
it's a kaleidoscope image it looks a
little different to everyone but one
thing that's clear from any perspective
is that this is truly been an
exceptional year for independent cinema
as you will see today starting with
these nominees for Best Supporting
female Ashley Bell as a young woman
possessed in the last exorcism we're
going to go down Vicky as a tougher than
nails matriarch of the secretive Ozark
community in Winter's Bone yeah you here
for trouble are you no ma'am
was one of my nephew's is Buster Leroy
and didn't he shoot your daddy one time
yes that ain't got nothin to do with me
they settled that themselves I think
shooting him like I said Odie allison
janney as a woman tormented by the past
and life during wartime
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't want to figure out
Daphne Ruben Vega a wife confined by a
crumbling marriage and Jacko's bode I
wanted to show up okay okay forget it
we're done
forget it okay okay Naomi Watts as a
successful but unhappy lawyer who goes
through a life-altering change and
mother and child
I value my independence above all things
that way I don't have any expectations
to fulfill other than my own but you're
great enough that's all she wrote and
the Spirit Award goes to
[Music]
Dale Dicky winters Bob
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you film independent
Thank You voters thank you film
independent community for this lovely
lovely honor I'm very thrilled to be
here take a deep breath I have to thank
Joel McHale for my new bruises from my
holding the chainsaw between my knees
for that coming the other day Thank You
Joel
being a part of this of this film this
year has just been an incredible ride a
little tiny film with some dark subject
matter and there's so many people to
thank for Winter's Bone and you all know
who you are but the entire cast and crew
particularly those on the day of the
boat scene that endured the pond water
and ticks I thank you
Debra Granik and Rosselini Alex Madigan
terrific women thank you for making me a
part of this anonymous content roadside
attractions has just been an incredible
group of people the cast and crew
my agents Carrie Barden impulsion II
that brought me in on this project and I
have seen so many fabulous smoothy's
shorts documentaries traveling with this
movie I'm so inspired by the independent
film community and I'm just very
grateful to be here a final shout out to
two places number one the people of
Missouri who open their hearts and their
land we love you you know who you are
there I share this with you as well as
my hometown Knoxville Tennessee and the
people of UT mom dad Chuck sister Fran
my husband Steven everyone thank you
very very much
[Applause]
hi my name is James Franco here's the
first of today's best feature nominees
127 hours the routes through here but I
know a better way all you have to
remember that everything will be ok
yeah see there Aaron is it true you
didn't tell anyone where you were going
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by Acura Acura at fans
[Music]
the 2011 Spirit Awards will continue
once we splash some cold water on Joel's
face and whisper inspirational messages
into his ears up next Jeremy Renner
Nicole Kidman and the award for best
male lead
[Music]
all right everybody please sit welcome
back sit please
yeah all right hey in an attempt to make
this as much like an independent movie
set you guys as you can see we have
slicked down the stage with water so
that you may hurt when you fall so just
be careful up here and we don't have any
insurance just like a regular movie set
for an independent film so all right uh
we are two awards away from handing out
the award for best male lead what a
category john c reilly Ben Stiller
James Franco Aaron Eckhart's and Ronald
Bronstein
when I heard that Ronald Bronstein was
nominated I said to myself what is my
dentist doing on this list
I'm kidding Ronald you were incredible
in daddy-longlegs where are you Ronald
I don't know I don't think so I don't
believe you so whatever um okay between
their appearances on Arrested
Development the increasingly poor
decisions of Todd Margaret and tonight's
show our next presenters pop up on IFC
more than Harvey Keitel's penis please
welcome David Cross and Will Arnett
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and the winner for best first
feature what are you doing I'm reading
the winner yeah well you can't just jump
to it you got a read who's nominated
first well but it's their first feature
come on surely they're not accorded the
same respect as veterans who've been in
this business for years right isn't
there some sort of hazing ritual what
you mean like with the Academy yeah yeah
no no it's not like that in this furies
know there's uh no no hazing of the
freshmen class over here really but I
know I know I know everyone remembers
Spike Lee being humiliated by the
Academy the first time when he had to
like stand in him bucket of Clint
Eastwood's urine in the middle of the
405 or something shouting I'm a pretty
little girl but I still want to get
spanked yeah yeah yeah yeah but that was
his idea yes no I know but still I'm
saying it's different and there's no
cutoff time for for acceptance speeches
here so oh that's awesome
yeah what about a cutoff for
presentation banter yes oh because
what's happening in Wisconsin people is
a call to arms ed yes asshole Jesus the
nominees are best first feature
everything strange and new the middle
path is Buddha would say the food is
full of shit I drink that
get low you want to have the funeral
party while you're alive so you can go
yes or no yes night catches this you
want to have a say about how things go
around here you have to stick things the
chain snitch I'm in charge now
the Last Exorcism if you can't say my
daughter so I will Tiny Furniture family
what are you gonna be sitting in our
house okay I thought I thought I was
gonna marriage just move to Colorado cut
me some slack and the winner is
get low
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you film independent and I want to
I want to thank our cast the wonderful
Robert Duvall Bill Murray Sissy Spacek
Lucas black it's a labor of love it took
five years took Dean ten years to get
the film off the ground and this is a
wonderful end to a long journey like to
thank my crew my DP David Boyd costume
designer Julie Weiss and Dean thank you
film independent this is a wonderful
culmination to a very long and arduous
but ultimately incredibly rewarding
journey and to be honored tonight is is
just a great way to cap it off it
wouldn't be possible without the
tremendous talents of our director and
editor Aaron Schneider and the brave and
deep pockets of our financier and fellow
producer David Gunn lack and of course
our distributor Sony Pictures Classics
Tom and Michael thank you so much
and the bottom line and it had to be on
the page so Chris provenzano and Charlie
Mitchell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and now please give a warm welcome to a
past spirit Awards nominee Jeremy Renner
and a nominee for best female lead here
today Nicole Kidman
acting is acting except when it comes to
independent films and the opportunity to
play unusual characters and play them in
unexpected ways is one reason why so
many of us jump at the chance to return
to independent film whenever we can
independent films are never easy to make
although we love independent films we
don't do these parts for love we do them
for money of course no we do them
because the hard work of playing
three-dimensional very human characters
as opposed to a likeable cliche is what
makes good actors great these actors all
took that chance and look what happened
the nominees are
Ronald Bronstein as in loving but
recklessly free-spirited father and
daddy longlegs the kids have been told
in advance that if daddy has an
emergency they're going to see there's
no danger in that you know what I'm not
entertaining this discussion - hello
this is my screw-up I'm entitled to
screw up in my two weeks and you can
screw up for the rest of the year ok
Aaron Eckhart as a loving husband trying
to hold himself and his family together
after a shattering tragedy in
rabbit-hole it's not a fountain video
Becky it's it's not about the video such
as the video it's about Tazz and the
paintings and his clothes and everything
there's no pictures of them around there
don't finger protector hi
you have to stop erasing come you have
to stop
James Franco this description is kind of
awesome James Franco as a merry mountain
climber on a delightful adventure and
120/70 cut his arm off man mom I love
you and I wish that I'd returned to all
your calls ever I love you guys and I'll
always be with you a lonely single man
stuck in a merit are in a romantic
triangle with the woman of his dreams
and her son in Cyrus what am i doing I'm
gonna mess this up you're not messing it
up are you flirting with me I'm like
Shrek
ben stiller as Akram Majin trying
desperately to avoid happiness and
greenberg think about your kids as
you're all kind of insensitive there's a
confidence in you guys it's horrifying
it's you're all a DD and carpal tunnel
hope I die before end up meeting when
you're in a job interview and the Spirit
Award goes to James Franco 125
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
goodness uh well I just went through
film school at NYU and I just finished
my thesis film and so independent film
is something that's very very a very big
part of my life and very important to me
and so this this means a lot and I have
a lot of people to thank first of all I
would not be here and this movie would
not have been made if it wasn't for Aron
Ralston and his uh his faith in us his
faith and Danny and it was a big big
gift so thank you thank you Aaron this
was a very unusually structured movie I
didn't have very many actors to act off
as it with so the the crew and the
director and the writer they all became
my co-stars in a way and we all had this
one character to share and I it was my
body but we were all kind of jammed in
there and it was a it was a crazy crazy
experience that I don't think I'll ever
repeat so I don't think they'll make
another movie like this Danny I it was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience so thank
you thank you very much Simon you give
crafted we crafted a script in arc with
one character you know I
I don't know how you did it but you did
it the cinematographers I don't know if
they're here but you know completely
innovative filmmaking
I was in awe and blown away
producers Fox Searchlight who had faith
in this this movie that basically you
know you look at it and it it is what it
is and it's crazy and they made it
anyways and thank you so much Lisa Marie
Kyle Cohn is gonna kill me if I don't
think her so thank you Lisa Marie and
then my manager my agent and my
publicist have been with me since the
very beginning first agent I met first
manager I had and almost the first
publicist I had and I was in school I
probably would have not it sounds crazy
but I probably would have not have done
this movie if they hadn't said James
you're F an idiot if you don't do this
movie with Danny Boyle so Thank You
miles Cammy and Robin thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
as you all know I got my career started
by being a dancer that's how I made any
money and so it's a great honor to
introduce one of the Best Picture
nominees Black Swan or new Swan queen
the exquisite Nina Sayers where'd you
get this it's nothing that's she doing
here
he made me your alternate have to be the
only person standing in your way is you
feel my tie to my sweet girl
[Applause]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by HTC at HTC every
innovation we create is inspired by you
coming up Jesse Eisenberg and rosario
Dawson present best documentary for more
of the 2011 Independent Spirit Awards
don't do anything just stay seated and
keep watching yes that's perfect
hi hi everybody how y'all doing tonight
yeah
my name is Craig Robinson it's my
privilege here today yeah it's my
privilege here today to introduce the
winners of our four special grant Awards
which are given to up-and-coming
filmmakers these awards are made
possible by the generosity of a
dedicated group of sponsors
oh yeah sexy sexy young filmmakers so
young so talented so fine
Fonfon sponsors so sexy Aveeno skincare
active natural fine and natural sponsors
the to 200 fiction award Aveeno products
rub them all over your beautiful sexy
body let's take a shower let's take a
shower together and resume of Acura
Acura Motor Vehicles so sexy there's
someone to watch a war I want to watch
your baby
I wanna watch it baby I wanna watch it
baby I want to watch you rub your
nipples baby I want to get in my a key
running come here come here come here
come come to you baby I'm in a romantic
mood for some afternoon talented
filmmaking love it you know what I'm
talking about
check it out
Piaget
yeah classic class of Piaget award for
classy classic filmmaking produces a war
Piaget produces I want to reproduce with
you I want to reproduce with you child
support take my damn watch I don't care
he is a proud to be associated with the
spirit of all you see that fine Brahma
whiskey right here
[Music]
fine fine filmmaking and beautiful sexy
big-ass titties you know what I'm
talking about Jon Hamm don't you know
what I'm talking about
[Music]
precious filmmaking lady you don't need
a lot of money for your films cuz
Jameson helps you with your find your
audience award we don't need no audience
just you and me and a Filipino
transvestite
Jamison that could be on safer Timmy -
safer tipping a safer but don't see you
right now I need a little boat thank you
here's the first of tonight's grant
award winners
[Applause]
[Music]
Marwin call is the story of mark logan
camp and his photography as soon as I
saw his photographs I was immediately
captivated I just had all these
questions and I knew I had to meet him
so I arranged to fly to New York and
brought a camera with me
Marwin call is this imaginary world that
he lives in which is a one-sixth scale
world war two themed town where he plays
out dramas and some that relate directly
to his real life over the four years
that I ended up shooting him it was
really this organic process and to me
winning the Aveeno truth and fiction
grant means that I'm gonna be able to
make a second film and that's a real
gift so thank you so much too you know
and thanks to FM independent
here they are Jesse Eisenberg and
rosario Dawson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of a novel or a screenplay these
days filmmakers young and old dream of
making the great American documentary
the results of this boom and nonfiction
filmmaking is that the craft has become
better and the stories have become
stronger and more varied documentaries
inspire us all through both the tales
they tell and the way they tell them and
this year's list of nominees you'll find
films that employ the time-honored
technique of patient observation and
others that play with the conventions to
tell a story in a new and innovative way
yes the nominees are Best Documentary
exit through the gift shop trio as a
short lifespan so it made a document to
Marwin called this is me after the
attack of course sweetgrass
this is bullshit mom I'm running my guts
out my dog some sort of foot that he
can't walk but I sniff up your no-man's
land
first friend I lost was Restrepo Thunder
soul it wasn't just play it was what we
put into it
[Music]
and the spirit award goes to exit
through the gift shop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know what to say it's too big
for me right now I had a speech but I
forgot it at the hotel so you know this
is me I would like to thanks everybody
work with me and everybody who worked on
the film I would like to to give this to
Banksy you know to you know to be the to
be the one that I film like crazy for
many years and I have so many tapes and
I don't know you know I never watched
one of them you know and he's the one
who really like took the time to watch
them you know so I thank him very much
for doing that you know and I would like
to to to make everybody that if you have
a dream you know that that it's possible
just make it possible into your heart
you know because it's possible to do it
you know it's like if you really want to
do something in life you can really make
it happen
you know just believe it you know
believe it so much and something will
happen you know there is no way
no way cannot happen you know with where
I come from and where I am now it's you
know what even the plane cannot take you
there you know it's like so big you know
so it's like it's like a comic strip
here you know it's it's not real but I
am real and the movie is real and it's
not real it's just real time right now
it's happening at now you know and I
would like to to give a kiss of every
one of you guys here
it's a lot of it but it's all from the
bottom of my heart you know I love you
all I love everyone and and somewhere
follow you dream you know follow your
dream
hello I'm Greta Gerwig and here is our
next best feature nominee greenberg
[Applause]
these days right now really trying to do
nothing for a while youth is wasted on
the young right go further
I'd go life is wasted on people can we
take it slow I just got out of a long
relationship and I don't want to go from
just having sex to just to having sex to
just having sex who's the third just
having sex you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by Stella Artois she is a
thing of beauty up next Naomi Watts and
Ewan McGregor present the prestigious
Robert Altman award the 2011 Independent
Spirit Awards continues with your host
Joel McHale if he's done trying to feel
up Jeremy Renner
[Music]
welcome back everyone
please take your seats please
alright here we go a big part of any
awards show is the in memoriam tribute
montage that's where we honor all of the
artists craftspeople and performers who
are no longer with us
and it's always the most depressing part
of the show for the audience because
there is absolutely no chance we'll get
to see footage of ourselves well that is
about to change you see here at the
Spirit Awards we consider ourselves to
be trailblazers to be ahead of the curve
and one step ahead of more traditional
award shows so with that in mind here's
a brief look ahead to some people who
may die next year our 2011 Independent
Spirit Awards in memoriam honorees of
the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and now here to present the Award for
Best Foreign Film our two fine Americans
Terrence Howard and Sandra Oh
and I noticed the Independent Spirit
Awards but we can afford some heat so
Terrence and I are very pleased to
present the Award for Best Foreign Film
yeah that's what we're doing and here
are the nominees best foreign film
kisses you don't find what you're gonna
be an end of people then you have to kid
with this Mademoiselle Shambo of gods
and men little commercial appraisals
allow me Donna Minister The King's
Speech do you know any jokes timing
isn't my strong suit
uncle Bumi who can recall his past lives
in a Mitel you say that
and the spirit award goes to the King's
Speech Tom Hooper
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you so much
to the film Independent Spirit Awards I
must admit I never thought I would be
able to win an award for Best Foreign
Film so I'm extremely grateful I know
the film has a lot of stammering and
stuttering in it so maybe it's
acknowledgement of that I'd like to
thank my amazing cast the wonderful
Colin Firth Helena Bonham Carter
Geoffrey Rush Guy Pearce Sir Michael
Gambon Sir Derek Jacobi Jennifer Ely the
great Claire Bloom it was extraordinary
ensemble to work with I'd like to thank
David Seidler this journey began for him
in the Second World War as a small boy
with a dreadful stammer and to go on
this journey with him to this award is
is fantastic I'd like to thank my
producers Gerrit ammidon
Ian canning this was a truly independent
movie and in you know what you had to do
to wrangle all the forces to make this
possible at a time when no one wanted to
make this movie and I want to thank in
for that I want to thank the weinstein
company momentum pictures I want to know
and I want to thank all my cast and crew
and mainly I want to say it's great to
be standing here at a celebration of
independent film with the film that was
made against the odds and have come on
this journey and I want to thank you all
very much
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
please give an insouciant and yet
jae-joon Independent Spirit Awards
welcome to you and McGregor and a
nominee for Best Supporting female Naomi
Watts
the Robert Altman award is given every
year to the cast casting director and
director of an independent film in which
the ensemble becomes much more than the
sum of its parts
this year the Robert Altman award honors
a filmmaker whose body of work is part
of an ongoing narrative a miniature
history of our times told through the
lives of comfortable yet restless and
troubled people here's the film that
Nicole hollofson er and her own
independent film community made together
please give high no we're happy I'm
keeping this $20 your guilt is warping
you why isn't it warping you your guilt
is warping me how's your sandwich
grandma mine's not good nice bed you
want some of mine no yours which begs me
this find that apartment has absolutely
no downside the grandmother gets to live
there we're not hovering
Sandra make a wish and start
construction
please please welcome the cast and crew
from please give
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow this is wonderful
it's a huge honor to be given an award
in Robert Altman's name obviously and
I'm thrilled so thank you so much film
independent and I want to thank Sony
Pictures Classics for making the film
and everybody back there
I want to thank Anthony Bragg Anthony
Bregman for making this movie and your
amazing aunt I wish you were here and I
want to thank also um Rob phrasing for
editing this movie and editing all these
people so beautifully and the actors who
aren't here before I thank all the
actors that are here Louis Smith is not
here and Rebecca Hall is not here and
Oliver Platt is not here but they're
very much a part of what was a wonderful
experience for me and look who I have
it was amazing
and gilbert and i know i especially want
to thank catherine who's been in every
one of my movies without who am i i
don't know i just don't know what they
would have been like or what i would
have been like or thank you sweetie
it's been amazing thank you everybody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right the red light zone so won't
you start off telling everyone your name
oh so long you tell us about the film
the movie Little Rock is about poor you
piss me off all you have to do is point
and shoot the camera that's it all right
so what would you like to think I want
to thank Acura so much for the money and
to film independent you have no idea how
much this means to us and gonna help us
finish our movies thank you so much
perfect frame yeah it looks great
all right real quick while Mike's out of
the car
Acura please hook me up seriously I got
a bus at Lincoln just need anything oh
here he comes
[Applause]
[Music]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by Acura Acura advance
[Music]
still to come Diego Luna Carrie
Washington and Rainn Wilson when we
return with more of the 2011 Independent
Spirit Awards the only movie awards show
on the planet that you are watching
right now
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody from my money you
can't make a human centipede without our
next two presenters please welcome my
middle Melissa Leo and my caboose Rainn
Wilson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi there how's it going Pablo but no oh
we're here to celebrate the fine
performances of our Best Supporting male
nominees
this is Nicole this fucking award show
ever but warm of heart the nominees are
John Hawkes Winter's Bone
John Hawkes this is me run together for
coming on 40 years but I don't know
where he's at and I ain't gonna go
around and ask and a half dream neither
no samuel l.jackson I met someone two
months ago but if that's my child you
carry I'm going to say goodbye to all
that Bill Murray done a hell of a job
for him you know so watches been the
inside of my coat I'm not ashamed of it
I know prob banks don't cheat at cards I
sleep all right nights I sleep John
Ortiz should have told you before you my
fucking friend she said it was a
one-time thing then we got an honest
fucking one out for two years two years
she said Mark Ruffalo
did you ever playing sport in school Wow
team thing just got on my nerves after a
while let's go kick some ass man and
what about you I like teams
and the Spirit Award goes to John Hawkes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well thanks so much begin with I think
thank my fellow nominees honored to just
be mentioned alongside of you so being
up here is kind of surreal but uh thanks
to everyone who worked on Winter's Bone
cast and crew the greatest across the
board I wish I could mention every cast
and crew member but I guess that's what
IMDB is for well a lot of the folks look
him up by the way they're they're
top-notch and hire them for your films I
have to say a special thank you to
Jennifer Lawrence for her amazing
amazing work she was she was brave and
she was always there very present
present actress and I can't wait to see
what what the future holds for you Jen
and Debra Granik the best of the best
thank you so much for giving me a shot
with this and for your encouragement and
for your patience
I'm gonna list a few people and then get
out get out of here but uh I think
roadside attractions for do it's just a
great part part with the doing their
part with the film I think Tamara
McClintock and Scott cloudless Tim
metier and Jim for its allure
Michelle sadder Nancy green-keyes JB
Robert Steve Lamanna
Todd Rubenstein Karen Sanfilippo I'm
forgetting a lot of people but cousin
Michael Utkin thank you tisha Esposito
my sweetheart I love you so much and
Terry Scott Laurie my mom and dad thank
you so much and he encouraged her the
love and finally to independent
filmmakers everywhere keep telling these
stories we need them stay wild
[Applause]
and now ladies and gentlemen please
welcome kerry washington and diego luna
the life of John Cassavetes in karpin's
encompass both the joys and the struggle
of independent film the nominees this
year for the John Cassavetes award which
honors filmmakers who carry on in the
Cassavetes tradition are the John
Cassavetes award lovers of hate I'm not
gonna find you here
thanking your monkey of solidia obse Li
dia I shouldn't be OBS technically the
exploding girl dear will have babies
right
and the spirit award goes to daddy
longlegs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone
yeah you know where there's no hope
there's no doubt we weren't expecting to
win
Ronald Bronstein the dentist as somebody
said earlier a true performer and you
know before I rattle off a bunch of
names of people who made this movie
happen
I don't know movies like this you know
they're small and we like to champion
not ambivalence in like a weak sense but
ambivalence in you don't know how you
feel about something because you're
conflicted by both of them both love and
hate I love my dad I hate my dad I love
my mom I hate my mom this movie is for
my dad our dad and our mom of course and
and he actually told us not to tell him
for some reason he wants to have the
gamble of waiting until later to see if
anything he bet on this award
he's a bet had terrible gambler but yeah
Casey and I said Tom Scott producer Sam
Lysenko Elaine or Hendricks actress and
Dakota gold horror actresses of course
Lia singer the mother and Lia Lee
Ranaldo of the sage & Frey the mother of
two kids who I stopped on the street and
and risked coming across you know I came
across as a pedophile and and and it all
worked out in the end and I never
touched either of them and I love them
both and I think that they were really
great and again Ronald Bronstein's
performance you know Ronnie I love you I
really do I love you the arguments that
we went through arguments support
everything in life I don't know and you
know Joanne while I'm sorry no you know
I just wanted to jump in and so this
award is for making a movie for a half a
million bucks or something and we made
this movie for no money but I just
wanted to speak to the resourcefulness
of these guys and like every time we hit
an obstacle they'd figure out a way to
overcome it like the Natural History
Museum saying we can't shoot in there
them like we just snuffed the camera in
a backpack so they're telling us wrap up
now when when he fell on stage that cut
into ours Thanks thank you speed long
live John Cassavetes honestly for was a
dream we'd have no American independent
cinema thank you very much to everyone
who actually saw the film thank you
ladies and gentlemen please rise for our
national treasure mr. John Waters
earlier today before the cameras arrived
we presented two very important awards
the Spirit Award for Best Cinematography
was given to Matthew Liberty for Black
Swan stand up and wave your award so we
know where you are please
and the Spirit Award for Best first
screenplay was given to Lena Dunham for
Tiny Furniture congratulations thank you
[Applause]
HTC congratulate the cast and crew of
get low on their spirit award win for
Best first feature and congratulations
to Best first screenplay winner Lena
Dunham for tiny furniture at HTC every
innovation we create is inspired by you
up next Paul Rudd and Ava Mendez when
the 2011 Independent Spirit Awards
continues
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Benita sub Jonny I am a grant
recipient for the ups a producer support
for the film eats cut off you don't know
much about women do you Stephen week
well now I think you're flirting with me
man the challenge of making this film
was shooting on location you know in
extreme conditions and extreme terrain
but we had a very willing casting crew
that's what you think that we lost I'd
say that seems about the right word for
it
we're not lost we just find I'm not wait
it was a lot of fun a lot of hard work
but very rewarding and we're all very
proud of the final film we're gonna make
it alright I certainly hope so now that
I've won that piace producers award I
hope to to put those resources behind
our next project I want to say thank you
to film independent in to Piaget for
making this grant possible I think so
many independent filmmakers have to give
up so much along the way and oftentimes
their fees so it's a nice reminder that
the sacrifices that filmmakers have to
make
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody before we continue with
the rest of the statue giving out thing
I need to make just a few announcements
restrooms are located on either side of
the tempt out of the tent not in an
empty bottle beneath your table and no
I'm not only talking to you Jon Hamm Kay
Walsh will you please report to the
production trailer there is an
implausible medical emergency and we
need someone to perform an ill-advised
procedure please stop somewhere on the
way and fall in love and will mr. Tom
Barnard from Sony Pictures Classics
please stop pitching your project to the
actors in attendance no one is
interested in appearing in fart police
all right I didn't have time to spot
check the script for this next intro but
please welcome affable everyman ava
Mendez and Latina bombshell Paul Rudd
well Paul and I are really disappointed
because we had a really funny bit but
apparently we're running late on time
and they've cut it but Paul was gonna
grab my tits you guys are gonna be
shocked horrified and you guys were
gonna laugh hysterically but apparently
we can't do that anymore because we're
out of time so the nominees for Best
Screenplay are Best Screenplay
Stewart Bloomberg and Lisa Cholodenko
why'd you get its birth she seemed like
a lot more fun than your donating blood
Debra Granik and Anne Rosellini new
donors have scared me that's cuz you're
smart
Nicole Hall Center we gained weight
thank you David lindsay-abaire they're
tons of yourself and theirs doesn't
means
like somewhere out there I'm having a
good time
Todd Solondz I have no illusions that
what I do is of interest to anyone else
are you seeing anyone no I'm more
focused on China
[Applause]
best screenplay Bloomberg
[Applause]
here comes Lisa
you know when this is sort of emotional
when Lisa and I started the script seven
years ago we were we were just a couple
of lesbians with a hope and a dream and
it's just great to be here now I just
want to thank Lisa for being such a
wonderful partner and I don't want to
run over so I want to give Lisa a little
chance at least I want you stepped in
here yes briefly um Stewart the most
potent sperm donor I've ever met
Bart Walker and Jeff levy hinty Kusama
hinty for some irrational confidence and
and sticking through all this you guys
were my guys still need were Trey and
Gary Gilbert for pushing that rock over
the hill everybody at focus for doing
one supreme job my beautiful Wendy and
our beautiful kid called her for giving
me reason to do all this and I think
that's it no there's one thing that we
wanted to do for seven years
thank you thank you
and now please put on your 3d glasses
and give your attention to the LG 3d
television monitors for an important
message from Howard Herlihy film
independence vice president of voting
processes and procedures hello
each year I have the distinct honor of
explaining to you exactly how the spirit
awards are determined now this year
certain people have asked me to spice
things up a little bit so if you will
all put your 3d glasses on we will
proceed with my presentation in 3d now
the Spirit Awards are determine our in
the Howard you don't need the glasses
you know the audience wears the glasses
okay sorry sorry the Spirit Awards are
determined in a 3-step process step one
the eligible Howard if you don't mind
just try can you try using this pointer
and just point that right into camera
for me when are we pointing it point
right at camera think 3d and action step
one the eligible films are submitted and
the eligibility is verified late let's
cut up step two
nice and big films are screened by oops
you know what Howard that was one quick
thing I want to double them that car
focus right up your nose great you're
good at this marker you're just looking
at camera smile see that 3d can you do
step step two with your friend there
okay we ain't the films are screened by
the community members who then prepare a
list of nominees marker bubbles are
great in 3d power you make bigger
bubbles that floats lower no keep your
script going try to hit this are you
trying step three deal that 3d that's 3d
when it comes to the camera like that
Hales Lake votes are tabulated by a No
shoot it right at us good 3d Howard and
the winners with me enough but go and
then the winners will be announced right
in the ultra right here even more right
okay right here today how'd that feel
for you our good for me if it's good for
you perfect
I need to do one more
[Applause]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by LG LG Cinema 3d the
next-generation 3d TV next Ben Stiller
present the Award for Best Director when
the 2011 Independent Spirit Awards
continues
[Applause]
[Music]
and now back by popular demand please
welcome Ben Stiller
[Applause]
hold so cold
[Applause]
as some of you may remember last year I
was made honorary chairman of the
Independent Spirit Awards now I'm being
told that they wish to abolish the
honorary chair position and I have been
asked to step down I would like to say
this to the people of the independent
film community
I will not now or ever step down and and
to my supporters I say dance sing
prepare for we will retaliate and at the
suitable time I will open the weapons
depot and armed every member of the
Screen Actors Guild and so help me
together we will turn Hollywood into a
red raging fists of fire
now the nominees for Best Director Best
Director Darren Aronofsky seduces come
on bucket
[Applause]
[Music]
Danny Boyle ever since it was a bit of
media right it's been waiting to come
here Lisa Cholodenko so it's my fault no
just listen to me I'm listening
what Debra Granik denied I ain't doing a
fucking thing you say
[Music]
John Cameron Mitchell some point it
becomes bearable Darren Aronofsky asked
me to lie and say his name if I opened
it and wasn't him Darren Aronofsky
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you very much it's a
very hard room Ben thanks for calming
everyone down believe it or not this was
a really hard film to make when we first
began and so the people who actually
made it I really need to single out now
it's so first Fox Searchlight they they
really I mean first of all it's an honor
to work with Fox Searchlight I'm really
spoiled they work with all my heroes
Danny Boyle and so many great filmmakers
and to actually be on their roster and
having done two films with them Thank
You Nancy Steve and Claudia for putting
your necks out because this was on paper
a really stupid move and Procrit you
know releasing the film so well Diana
and Melissa and everyone at Fox thank
you guys and then no one believed in it
and they took some equity and the only
people dumb enough were some crazy
people from Louisiana and Texas led by
their fearless leader Brian Oliver at
Cross Creek thank you guys they made a
really really terrible deal to make this
film and everyone was like you'll never
make money but now they're fucking rich
so it's great
it's great thank you guys
and then my producing partner who
started off actually as an intern at
protozoa my company and now is my
partner and really fought day and night
for about 12 months to get the money for
the film Scott Franklin great producer
but ultimately I think it comes down to
I mean I'm a director so I have to think
that my most important tool which is my
actors I've been really lucky to like
have fearless performances and and for
all that trust I'm thankful from the
beginning from PI from Sean ban and Mark
and from Requiem from Jared Jennifer
Marlon and an Alan Burstyn and from the
fountain from Rachel and Hugh and and
now from the wrestler from Mickey Rourke
and and Marissa and Evan and then
finally this film you know having Mila
Kunis and Barbara Hershey and went on a
Ryder and vincent cassell as your colors
it's amazing and then to have this
incredible performer give you everything
she's got and trained for a year I will
always be in debt to miss Natalie
Portman thank you very much
hi I'm Jennifer Lawrence and this is
Winter's Bone Jessup signed over
everything if he doesn't show it trial
y'all gonna lose his house you got
someplace to go before we get kicked off
our own property
I reckon y'all got this place about
another week you've got something safe
you bet said now turn us out to live in
the field like dogs
there's stuff that you're gonna have to
get over being scared of is this gonna
be our time the 2011 film Independent
Spirit Awards are presented by Acura
Acura advance next Jamie Foxx and Zoe
Saldana present the award for best
female lead in the 2011 Independent
Spirit Awards continues
[Music]
hi my name is Jeff I'm the director of
Marwan call I'm Chris I'm one of them
producers of my own and we're here in
New York City the films been playing
here for five weeks so we wanted to get
some indication of what impact we're
making on New York audiences so here we
go all right can you guys pronounce that
word Marwan call and if you had to guess
what would you say that is a person
sounds like an indigenous tribe no idea
[Music]
so clearly we have a lot of work to do
we would like to thank Jamison and film
independent from the bottom of our
hearts for the Jamison find your
audience award which is gonna help us go
and find our audience which we haven't
shot down okay one more time thank you
welcome back I'm Joel McHale or as
Charlie Sheen calls me Mordechai
Rabinowitz and now please welcome two of
my favorite cousins on my maternal side
Zoe Saldana and Jamie Foxx
[Applause]
I know every presenter feels that the
award they present a special but only
one award can be best female lead and
that's this one the nominees are best
female lead and that Finan you're
sleeping with him aren't you
what just being honest with me okay
where's this coming from huh hmm I found
your hair in his drain Greta Gerwig I'm
impressed by you in what way
I mean you seem really fine doing
nothing it's like you don't feel the
pressure to be successful I mean by
other people's standards Nicole Kidman
there are tons of use out there and
there's doesn't means I like that
thought somewhere out there I'm having a
good time
Jennifer Lawrence Jessup Dali is dead
designing a crappy grave somewhere
become piles of shit in a hog pen maybe
he's been left out plain in the open
wherever he is he's their dead Natalie
Portman I'll be home soon I just want to
let you know hello Beach Michelle
Williams I've done okay I'm done I'm
done I'm done
look look I have no I am done I'm done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so much this is so meaningful to me this
is my first time here and I think it
speaks so much to the independent
filmmaking community that there could be
six incredible performances in this
category this year actresses I so admire
Annette Nicole Michelle who Greta
Jennifer you are all absolutely
inspirational to me and I watched
everything you do so so closely and
learned so much from it this was as
Darren said such an independent
filmmaking experience we had the bond
company on set for the last like two
months and it was like a two and a half
months shoot and you know my ballet
teachers everyday we're like so when do
we get paid and and really think Fox
Searchlight for for taking this this
risk with us and and also just to be
among all of these female filmmakers I
love Youth male filmmakers too but to
have you know Lena Dunham and Nicole
help Center and Lisa Cholodenko and
Debra Granik
I mean it's it's to recognize these
people in you know an industry with a
different set of standards is a great
honor to be in this room with you and I
just thank you thank you very much
slippery
[Applause]
[Music]
hello I'm Josh Hutcherson and I'm me
about Chicago and we're here to
introduce the kids are already each of
my mom's had a kid with your sperm
liking both of them uh-huh I can gay
right on I love lesbians great men and
that's cool
and now we can move on I'm gonna see him
again you do you do it's so great to
meet you go easy on the wine huh it's
daytime
okay same goes for the micromanaging
okay
[Applause]
the 2011 film Independent Spirit Awards
are presented by Stella Artois she is a
thing of beauty don't go away the final
award of the 2011 Independent Spirit
Awards is coming up next
and now to present the final award of
the evening two of the most well
respected actors of their generation and
the stars of next summer's fart police
uma Thurman and Don Cheadle
[Applause]
[Music]
oh wow it's cold down here a great film
it's a revelation it takes you somewhere
you've never been and shows you
something about other people than
yourself that you never knew revelations
on a budget that's our motto the five
films nominated for Best Feature are 127
hours black swan
greenberg
The Kids Are Alright
Winter's Bone
and the spirit award goes to Black Swan
[Applause]
wow what an honor thank you to film
independent we were here two years ago
and I thought that if we won here I'd
actually be less nervous standing up
here but nope
so it this was a really really hard film
to make and and I would also you know
for you know the sake of repeating what
Darren had to say thank everybody
involved and think everybody who came
every day to work on the film and and
everybody did get paid which which was a
nice thing I'd like to thank Fox
Searchlight and my directing partner
Darren who I I guess you can say intern
for and you know to work with Darren I
gotta say I got I am the luckiest
producer in this industry you know there
are times you feel like I feel I'm the
unluckiest producer but you know I'm
pretty lucky and thank you folks like
Cross Creek Mike Arne Phoenix and I
could thank my wife for her support me
getting there everyday and my two
children Mason and Brody and my parents
who are here this weekend but not here
so thank you everybody thank you thanks
everybody
the process of making and marketing
films and distributing is not to be this
difficult unfortunately usually is I'd
like to thank the Independent Film
Association for encouraging independent
spirit in all of us the there's
obviously a lot of people to thank
whenever any one of these kind of films
get made Fox Searchlight for doing an
amazing job of distributing the film I
mean a classic distribution plan
executed perfectly and I must say having
been in the business as long as I have I
don't think I've seen that many great
films distributed this way I want to
thank Darren it was really he was really
the chief of the whole thing the whole
process it's his vision that got the
film made it's his push and thank you so
much Darren for everything
natalie miele protozoa this guy right
here scott franklin for putting an
amazing team together and making it all
work without him i don't think this
thing would have gone as clockwork as it
did Brian Oliver for putting up the
money in the last minute when everything
seemed to be gone
Matthew for for making a great film the
writers and my wife
Irena who is at home not braving this
cold weather and my son Nicky and Brian
thank you everybody so much there can't
be any better partners than Darren
Aronofsky Natalie Portman and Fox
Searchlight we're grateful to you all
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations to all the winners
thanks for watching I'll see you all
next year when I expect multiple
nominations for my performance in Spy
Kids 4 good night everybody
[Applause]